yeah there's no room for fear in this
world in mine
forget that
has been a bit of a road I first saw
when walking when I was a tiny in my
early 20s I was bumping around I didn't
want to go to college I didn't know what
I wanted to do in life
saw an advert for my local airshow and
saw a nanosecond of a wing-walker go by
in a javelin and that was it I was owned
I decided to write that in there that
thought was gonna be the rest of my life
and it took me from that point seven
years of begging pleading every
wing-walking team in North America huh
to basically just even get me up in the
sky
[Music]
it's like being in a category 5
hurricane on a roller coaster from hell
with no way off because I'm a madwoman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
an airplane that you see behind me right
now in a weird twist of fate that's
actually the very first airplane that I
ever went walked on and now it's my
airplane and my life just wouldn't be
worth it if I couldn't wake up in the
morning you'll do this come on doesn't
look like the funny thing ever does the
reason I that's the reason I get out of
bed in the morning it's what makes me
smile it's what makes me not care if I
have to work 16 hours straight for five
days in a row I get to go and do this
appeal
anytime that you can aspire to see a
human
[Music]
another human being kind of achieved
their inner thing and that when you can
witness human triumph over adversity I
mean it just kind of motivates you to
[ __ ] be proud of your race it's like
when you see those great videos of dogs
doing super cool things doesn't just
make you love dogs same thing
[Music]
[Music]